Just what tricks do "The Batman" director
Matt Reeves and his crew have up their sleeves
for audiences?
Could the riddle be…on us?
Keep watching for one big twist the movie
has in store.
Batman has his hands full in the newest entry
to the Dark Knight movie mythos.
This time around, The Riddler is a serial
killer targeting Gotham's elite to bring their
corruption to light.
Catwoman seems like she may be an ally, but
as tends to be the case throughout her history
with the Bat, she causes her own share of
headaches.
And The Penguin rubs elbows with the most
dangerous criminals in all of Gotham through
his nightclub.
Batman's arguably the busiest person in Gotham,
and that's just the beginning of his problems.
However, people with fun nicknames who sometimes
wear costumes are only part of the equation.
There are plenty of criminals who keep a lower
profile, and that's where Carmine Falcone
enters the picture.
He's a crime lord who's awfully chummy with
Penguin and has a history of keeping the most
powerful people in the city under his thumb.
He's a menacing force that lurks in the shadows,
and while he may not be as flashy, he's just
as, if not more, terrifying.
Given his proclivity for criminal activity,
it makes one of the movie's primary twists
all the more shocking.
In "The Batman," Riddler sets out to reveal
a massive conspiracy in which Gotham's elite
power brokers took funds from the Wayne Foundation's
Renewal project.
That project had dedicated $1 billion per
year to help Gothamites, but the conspiracists
lined their own pockets instead.
But there's a rat in their midst, and The
Riddler wants this individual to come to light
to pay for their actions.
Batman and Police Lieutenant James Gordon
attempt to find this rat, knowing he'll be
the next Riddler victim.
They have several guesses initially with the
only clue being the Spanish phrase, "rata
alada," which roughly translates to "winged
rat."
At first, Batman assumes the rat must be the
Penguin, since penguins have wings.
When that turns out to be a dead end, he wonders
if he's at the center of this conspiracy somehow
since bats are sometimes derogatorily called
rats with wings.
But that's when he has the realization that
"Falcone" has "falcon" right there in the
name.
And falcons have wings!
"It all adds up to a sinister riddle.
Riddl-er.
Riddler?"]
It's a development that likely took plenty
of fans by surprise.
In the comics, Falcone is a ruthless mob boss
known as "The Roman" in honor of his ruthless
demeanor.
He keeps more to the shadows in "The Batman,"
and his turn as the rat is a significant departure
from his depictions in comics, TV shows, and
other movies.
No doubt it took plenty of audience members
by surprise, just one of the many shocking
moments to be found in "The Batman."
Carmine Falcone doesn't get a ton of screentime
in "The Batman," but he makes excellent use
of the scenes he does appear in.
It goes along perfectly with his attitude.
He can be a more effective crime lord if he
keeps a low profile and stays out of the public
eye as often as possible.
However, it's clear he gets into ample trouble
behind the scenes.
As it turns out, he's not just a rat, but
also the father of a Cat.
He's Selina Kyle, a.k.a.
Catowoman's dad.
Granted, some fans were probably more likely
to see this particular twist coming, seeing
how there's precedent for it in the comic
books.
Their relationship is hinted at in "The Long
Halloween" and its sequel.
In the movie, Catwoman knows for sure that
Falcone is her father, but he's completely
unaware of her existence.
He only learns the truth when she reveals
herself to him and mentions her mother, Maria
Kyle, to his face.
Selina Kyle may be okay with letting Falcone
live in the comics, but she's out for blood
in "The Batman," missing her chance for revenge
when Batman enters the picture and stops her
before she does something she might regret.
This isn't the first time Carmine Falcone
has appeared in a live-action film — he
was a key part of "Batman Begins" — but
Reeves and crew have created a terrifying
mobster who's unlike any iteration in the
past.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.